hi i'm jane pauley trying to find out
which shade of ballet slipper nail
polish is right for me today I'm
interviewing somebody close to my heart
close to your heart and close to being
arrested Katya who is Katya is Amal
Escobar who is she who is she I think
it's probably easier to say who isn't
she right she is not the girl next door
and yet she lives right in your front
yard she copied your homework but also
sold you a test and then she is the
substitute teacher she's the she's the
the mystery in the conundrum and the
CliffsNotes
and the miniseries what's your life's
motto that yeah yeah all encompassing
yeah what profession other than your own
would you most like to try
anesthesiologist absolutely really yeah
super high stakes we make a ton of money
every day there's like a new and fresh
opportunity for you to be responsible
for somebody's life so you can kill
somebody every day if he'll is real what
do you hope Satan says when you get
there
welcome back what do you consider to be
the most overrated virtue chastity is
that a virtue I don't see the point in
denying the world to experience your
body like you know cuz I'm a good person
but I will later yeah it doesn't make
any sense makes sense yeah what's your
favorite sound oh you know what like we
know horror movies with them the Darrell
a the the ugh like that when someone's
like pleading for their life and it's
sort of like an ugly cry with a lot of
mucus
I was like sexy time Dolph movie thank
you bleeding for your life come on okay
what is your favorite curse word I
really like when people say gosh darn it
you do yeah HG double hockey sticks yeah
what's your favorite Russian insult my
favorite that would be the penis dollars
like who's your hero I thought you
really say God you know that did that
did cross my mind
I don't know Amelia Earhart okay because
she says that to the con Jim yeah that's
Eli Whitney I know why do I know that
because the Industrial Revolution
fascinating textiles yeah
I'm insane Millie Earhart because I
think she's scamming us you do you think
that she's somewhere like with Tupac
yeah in the Cayman I think so she Park
and then um whitey bulger but they just
found him in and then I yeah yeah yeah
that got him like the name whitey
imagine going down with the name whitey
terrible yeah that's um that would be
like you're born and you came out
Caucasian and your mom and dad didn't
think of my name ahead of time they're
like whitey that's good for now right
and then they just never get around to
fixing it first of all [ __ ] yes you
know babies don't come out white they
come out purple oda purple you know what
I don't like in movies as when they
woman will give birth to a
three-year-old baby do you even like it
movies were like the baby's born but
they didn't get a real newborn well
right it's gonna it's a three-year-old
it's a toddler why in the Twilight
movies did they CGI the baby's face
that whole movie they're like look at
your band the baby's name is like nah
spurt what is it Bethesda it's something
and they're like look at your baby and
it's a CGI baby face like going gaga
have an adult face I think they wanted
to take the two actors who were the
parents and like create ah but it's not
seamless it looks like one of those like
snapchat face SWAT apps oh I'm here for
that it's like a huge Hollywood movie I
like that what is the baby's name it's
honestly like my Fez dennou I don't know
yeah yeah or Chris if you could go back
to college mmm-hmm would you have gone
as young as you did cuz you know no I
would not I would take off like probably
five years back when I was in school I
didn't know oh my god it was stupid it
was so Pollyanna when you're 18 knowing
I'm just gonna go for what I love yeah
don't go for you love no become a nail
tech yeah and then figure something out
get a nice vocation completely yeah do
you mean job experience matters more
than education sometimes like at us look
at this do you see what you see what's
going on here this is life this is the
long hard road right here don't you
think oh that's all the time we have and
if you'd like to spend more time with us
you can join us every week and the while
presents plus network with our show
we're entering our fourth season so
we're kind of good
[Music]